[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
they scan our show we have very loyal
viewers they watch the show carefully
they try and find a flaw so far many
challengers
no winners right nobody has found us
making a mistake you know and i think if
they were loyal they just let it slide
but no they have to be snotty yeah
exactly well recently we did a week of
shows in chicago and uh during the
chicago week i made a visit to the
lincoln museum and one of our viewers a
man named steve kershak
thinks he caught a mistake when i said
something about the emancipation
proclamation
let's take a look at his video
when you were at the lincoln
museum
you held up a shot glass that had the
emancipation proclamation on it and you
said it was the greatest uh piece of
legislation ever enacted the
emancipation proclamation
shot glass
one of the greatest
pieces
of legislation in mankind's history well
calling you did wrong i know that you
think that maybe i'm a skinhead
nazi who doesn't appreciate the
emancipation population but once again
you're wrong
you see the emancipation proclamation
wasn't the greatest legislation enacted
it was the greatest executive order ever
enacted
i catch a conan you're wrong
okay first of all two things
why bring up this whole nazi thing
out of the blue no one thought anything
i just thought it's a bald he's like hey
i don't get the idea i'm a nazi or
anything
well now i'm wondering right right
and the second thing is if you're making
an address to people on national
television can you keep it quiet in the
background
can we hear that again what are you
doing check this out it was the greatest
executive order ever enacted
i that's it it sounds like someone's
washing a dog and then putting it yeah
yeah in a buzzfeed in the dryer or
something yeah well anyway that's all
beside the point because i'm sorry steve
but you are dead wrong you have no idea
how the executive and legislative
branches work don't believe me check out
this ultimate authority
[Music]
the emancipation proclamation i'm
totally a piece of
legislation which means conan was
completely right in everything that he
said and you are wrong mr nazis in
skinhead
[Applause]
that song really holds up
if it rhymes it's got to be right if
it's rhymes it's got to be authentic so
the challenge still stands they still
haven't caught us if you think you've
spotted an error on our show reported
teamcoco.com
haha i found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chunk
meat
out of the maestro